what doesn't kill you just makes you
stronger
good practice get knocked down get right
back up again and get back to work
[Music]
just got the dogs out for a good run i'm
about to start working on my cabin it's
kind of been getting put off a long time
had a lot of other stuff on the plate
but the tent's kind of becoming
undesirable to live in and winter is
extremely set in here
winter's long but the daylight's short
and it's been some 20 25 below
temperatures and now the temperatures
are really starting to drop
nothing like some deep cold to get some
urgency
started this cabin you know before the
snow started flying
i've got everything sealed in i've got a
solid roof on it solid foundation
solid walls but what i need to do right
now is
get the roof insulated the daylight's
about to be gone
limited daylight is about four hours if
i work four hours a day
nothing's gonna get done so i mean i
could be cutting wood at three in the
morning running dogs three in the
morning filled in the cabin at three in
the morning
whatever it takes
you getting this cabin built just in
time the cold's really starting to move
in here
[Music]
got the first sheet cut here this is one
of those things it would be real nice to
have a second hand with but
this is where years of handling plywood
comes into play
this is gonna be the part that's not
very fun
[Music]
thank god i got some purchase on that
one
whenever i was 20 years old living in a
tent all winter was nothing
but i'm not 20 years old anymore i don't
recover i don't bounce back as quick
a person needs to feel human they need a
place to have their own
be dry be warm
[Music]
keep all their most important things out
of the weather
it feels good to get some momentum back
into this project hardest thing is to
get going sometimes
if you're going to be efficient and
effective out here you have to figure
out ways of killing two birds with one
stone
you got to think multi-dimensional
okay i got most of my plywood up on the
ceiling this area i need to leave open
because i'm going to start setting my
stove up here
this is kind of the exciting part
i'm really looking forward to getting
this wood stove in here because then i
can get myself a source of heat
i mean i've been living in a tin all
winter i'm out here working in the cold
all night
because i want to get this done get this
cabin
good enough that i can start moving my
stuff in it tonight
[Music]
you